We can see what might be relationships between price
and clarity and price and color, which we'll keep in
mind for later when start modelling our data. You might
remember this when you create the box plots in problem
set three. Be that as it may, the critical factor
driving price is the size, or the carat weight of
the diamond. As we saw at the start of the
lesson, the relationship between price and diamond size is nonlinear.
What might explain this pattern? On the supply side, larger
continuous chunks of diamonds without significant flaws are probably harder to
find than smaller ones. This might help explain the sort
of exponential looking curve, and I thought I noticed this when
I was shopping for a diamond for my soon to
be wife. Of course, this is related to the fact that
the weight of a diamond is a function of volume, and
volume is a function of the length times the width times
the height of a diamond, and this suggests that we might
be especially interested in the cube root of carat weight. It's often
the case, that leveraging substantive knowledge about your data like this can
lead to especially fruitful transformations, and we'll see that in a second.